Alice:更喜欢猫还是狗
Alice: Do you prefer cats or dogs?
Lucia: （歌词）around hope you tell me so my feelings should know
Lucia: (singing) Around, hope you tell me so my feelings should know.
Jake: 拍一个跟他们斗舞
Jake: Let's film a dance battle with them.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 啊哈
Lucia: Aha.
Katrina:  这不是空竹吧
Katrina: Is this not a diabolo?
Jake: 跟他们斗舞
Jake: Dance battle with them.
Jake: 斗是什么
Jake: What is "dou"?
Lucia: 好厉害啊
Lucia: That's awesome.
Tasha:  就是有一个棍子拼控制另一根棍子
Tasha: It's like using one stick to control another stick.
Katrina:  我们特别像一群异类如禽
Katrina: We look like a bunch of misfits.
Alice:能玩一下吗
Alice: Can we try it?
其他人：哎你好这个叫什么啊
Others: Hey, what's this called?
Lucia: 啊这个好想玩
Lucia: Ah, this looks so fun.
其他人：这叫花棍
Others: This is called a flower stick.
Alice:花棍
Alice: Flower stick.
Jake: 花棍
Jake: Flower stick.
Alice:花棍
Alice: Flower stick.
Jake: 像是那种打打扫厕所呵
Jake: It looks like something for cleaning toilets, haha.
Jake: 呵是
Jake: Haha, right.
Jake: 这练多久啊
Jake: How long do you need to practice this?
Jake: 能能练这样
Jake: To get this good?
其他人： 您练快
Others: If you practice quickly...
其他人：有个十天半月的
Others: About ten days to half a month.
Jake: 半个月半个月就会玩了
Jake: In half a month, you can play it well?
其他人： 对像你们这样快
Others: Yeah, for quick learners like you.
其他人：我们上岁数的就慢了
Others: For older people like us, it takes longer.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:我们能试一下吗
Alice: Can we give it a try?
其他人：能可以
Others: Sure, go ahead.
Jake: 哈哈谢谢您
Jake: Haha, thank you.
Lucia: 你试试
Lucia: You try it.
Alice:谢谢怎怎怎么发力呢
Alice: Thanks, how do you get the power?
其他人：发力这个这个
Others: Getting the power, this, this...
Jake: 要要要不哎
Jake: You need to, um...
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Whoa!
Jake: 哈哈绕了3圈挺厉害
Jake: Haha, three spins, that's impressive!
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:我发现转不起来
Alice: I can't get it to spin.
Alice:我能看下你是怎么开始的吗
Alice: Can I see how you start it?
其他人：可以这这不这不是拿下来都会
Others: Sure, it's not hard once you take it down.
其他人：你就得练
Others: You just need to practice.
其他人：你要是想练这个
Others: If you want to get good...
其他人：就是从这个基础学起
Others: You have to start with the basics.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:这样起来的
Alice: So it's like this.
其他人：掌握这个平衡
Others: Mastering the balance.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: So cool.
Alice:哦这样起来的
Alice: Oh, so that's how it works.
Alice:哦哦行
Alice: Oh, got it.
其他人：这这样调
Others: Adjust it like this.
其他人：能调你就调
Others: If you can adjust it, then do it.
其他人：偏过中心就行
Others: Just get it past the center.
其他人：偏过中心
Others: Past the center.
Alice:我能使两个棍弄起来吗
Alice: Can I use two sticks to do this?
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: That's impressive.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Jake: 你厉害
Jake: You're amazing.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人：不要抓这毛
Others: Don't grab that fur.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 不好意思不好意思
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Jake: 这毛
Jake: This fur...
其他人： 这就跟头发一样
Others: It's just like hair.
Jake: 这自怎么自己做的
Jake: Did you make this yourself?
Jake: 外边买
Jake: Bought it outside.
其他人： 开始时买的现在我自己做也卖
Others: I bought it when I started, now I make and sell it myself.
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 哦哦哦也卖哦
Jake: Oh, oh, you sell it too.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Jake: 要不咱两个扔试试
Jake: 哎呦厉害
Jake: Oh wow, impressive.
其他人： 两个的比一个的难度大多了
Others: Two are much harder than one.
其他人： 因为是一个左手一个右手
Others: Because it's one in the left hand and one in the right hand.
Jake: 这两个棍
Jake: These two sticks.
Jake: 两两两个棍两个棍
Jake: Two, two, two sticks, two sticks.
其他人： 哦两个棍
Others: Oh, two sticks.
Jake: 两个棍容易一点
Jake: Two sticks are a bit easier.
其他人： 这你也就看看热闹你如果想学这个从这个基础学起
Others: You can just enjoy the show. If you want to learn this, start with the basics.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah!
Jake: 转起来了
Jake: It's spinning now.
Jake: 就刚刚刚刚那一段
Jake: Just like that part earlier.
Jake: 然后就重复剪出来
Jake: Then just repeat and cut it out.
Jake: 重复你就一直转
Jake: Keep repeating, just keep spinning.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈GIF出来了
Jake: Hahaha, make a GIF out of it.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Jake: 够剪了够剪了够剪了
Jake: That's enough to cut, enough to cut.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 走吧下一个
Jake: Let's go to the next one.
Jake: 我们最后转到原来的位置
Jake: We'll finally return to the original position.
Jake: 这样整个公园就重建出来了
Jake: This way, the whole park is reconstructed.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice:啊差不多就围湖一圈
Alice: Ah, pretty much a circle around the lake.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:这个小亭子还挺凉快的通风
Alice: This little pavilion is quite cool and breezy.
Jake: 对这亭子挺好
Jake: Yeah, this pavilion is nice.
Lucia: （歌词）to fall so many times
Lucia: (Singing) to fall so many times
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:噢那个那个上面黏黏的
Alice: Oh, that thing is sticky.
Alice:他就增加那个粘性
Alice: It just increases the stickiness.
Lucia: 啊摩擦摩擦力吗
Lucia: Ah, friction, right?
Alice:嗯就那个皮上面有那个黏黏的油
Alice: Yeah, there's this sticky oil on the skin.
Jake: 哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Jake: 妙啊
Jake: Clever.
Katrina:  哎呦
Katrina: Ouch.
Alice:搓一下吧
Alice: Rub it a bit.
Jake: 湖水洗一洗
Jake: Wash it in the lake water.
Alice:太太臭了哈哈
Alice: It's too smelly, haha.
Shure: 还好有这个事顶一下不然就会被骂
Shure: Good thing we have this to cover it up, or we'd be scolded.
Katrina:  也可以往里走哎
Katrina: We can also go inside.
Alice:禁止钓鱼
Alice: No fishing allowed.
Lucia:（歌词） to end the fight
Lucia: (Singing) to end the fight
Lucia:（歌词） i had to fall so many times
Lucia: (Singing) I had to fall so many times
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 虽然有很多环卫工人
Jake: Although there are many sanitation workers.
Lucia: 可能他有点富营养化吧
Lucia: Maybe it's a bit eutrophic.
其他人：好专业啊
Others: So professional.
Jake: 是的专业
Jake: Yes, professional.
Lucia: 啊没有
Lucia: Ah, no.
Lucia: 我乱说的
Lucia: I was just guessing.
Lucia: 就是因为它有点发绿
Lucia: It's because it's a bit green.
Lucia: 然后又有泡泡
Lucia: And there are bubbles.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  外面走走看
Katrina: Let's walk outside.
其他人：好像在哪里看到过这个词
Others: Seems like I've seen this word somewhere.
Shure:  就是这吧
Shure: It's just this.
Tasha: 怎么办识别不出来
Tasha: What to do if I can't recognize it?
Lucia: 或许地理课上吗
Lucia: Maybe in geography class?
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Anything works.
Jake: 可以绕啊
Jake: You can go around.
Jake: 只要绕过去就行
Jake: Just go around, that's fine.
Lucia: （歌词）made of a night
Lucia: (lyrics) made of a night
Shure:  你带了头盔
Shure: You brought a helmet.
Shure:  可是没有插上
Shure: But you didn't plug it in.
Jake: 一会再插
Jake: We'll plug it in later.
Jake: 刚刚其实应该插一下
Jake: We should've plugged it in earlier.
Jake: 他一次只能录25分钟
Jake: It can only record for 25 minutes at a time.
Jake: 我要找到25分钟的那个时间段
Jake: I need to find that 25-minute mark.
Jake: 刚刚那段其实挺好的忘了
Jake: That last part was actually good, but we forgot.
Lucia: 严谨
Lucia: Detailed.
Jake: 看下一段
Jake: Let's check the next part.
Alice:这颜色好漂亮
Alice: This color is so pretty.
Alice:对呀
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha:  鸡爪7哦
Tasha: Chicken claw 7, oh.
Alice:好漂亮好漂亮
Alice: So pretty, so pretty.
Jake: 叫啥呀
Jake: What's it called?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 叫什么呀
Jake: What's it called?
Jake: 鸡爪7 鸡爪7
Jake: Chicken claw 7, chicken claw 7.
Tasha:  是的他长得像鸡爪子一样
Tasha: Yeah, it looks like a chicken claw.
Jake: 好想吃啊
Jake: Looks so tasty.
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 也想吃
Jake: Also looks tasty.
Tasha:  那我给你摘一片你吃吧
Tasha: I'll pick a piece for you to eat.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我还以为打开方式是
Lucia: I thought the way to open it was...
Lucia: 我们晚上吃鸡爪呢
Lucia: We were going to eat chicken claws tonight.
Jake: 呵呵是这个意思
Jake: Haha, that's what it means.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 呵呵来给我试叶子可能是
Jake: Haha, let me try the leaf, maybe it's...
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha:  这个
Tasha: This one.
Shure:  我说我说这里面有蛤蟆啊叫了
Shure: I said, I said there's a frog calling in here.
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Huh?
Shure:  听到了蟾蜍的叫声
Shure: I heard the sound of a toad.
Shure:  稍微践踏一下
Shure: Step on it lightly.
Jake: 找手串呢
Jake: Looking for a bracelet.
Shure:  我听到了
Shure: I heard it.
Lucia: hey i'm a just let my country i'm young scrubbing and hungry
Lucia: Hey, I'm just letting my country know, I'm young, scrubbing, and hungry.
Shure:  哈哈蛤蟆听取蛙声一片
Shure: Haha, the toad listens to the frogs croaking.
Lucia: Chinese culture read my goal my power speech only pitchable
Lucia: Chinese culture, my goal is to read, my power is speech, only pitchable.
Katrina:  嗯这个好看
Katrina: Hmm, this looks good.
Alice:想从这走过去
Alice: Want to walk through here.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 比谁走得快
Jake: Let's see who walks faster.
Jake: 到那个呃真的走
Jake: To that... uh, really walk.
Lucia: 不行底下都有水
Lucia: No way, there's water underneath.
Lucia: 没有落脚点
Lucia: No foothold.
Tasha:  很滑的
Tasha: It's very slippery.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 掉进去了的话
Lucia: If you fall in...
Lucia: AI就会捕获人类早期落水宝贵纪录
Lucia: AI will capture valuable early human water landing records.
Jake: 是这是他捕捉的最后一个信号
Jake: Yes, this is the last signal it captured.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哦然后进水就坏了是吗
Lucia: Oh, then it breaks when it gets wet, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:AI能不能理解我们为什么非要从这走
Alice: Can AI understand why we insist on walking through here?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 他就最后总结出人类都太不理性了
Lucia: It will finally conclude that humans are too irrational.
Lucia: 然后决定消灭人类吗
Lucia: And then decide to eliminate humans?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 我看了好多类似的科幻片哈哈
Lucia: I've watched a lot of similar sci-fi movies, haha.
Jake: 哦是吧
Jake: Oh, really?
其他人：桃花潭水深千尺
Others: The water in the Peach Blossom Pool is a thousand feet deep.
Shure:  go
Shure: Go.
Shure:  前面这条是京杭大运河
Shure: This is the Grand Canal ahead.
Jake: 哪一条啊
Jake: Which one?
Tasha:  真的吗潜在的这条河
Tasha: Really? This potential river?
Tasha:  我们就可以回家了阿sir
Tasha: Then we can go home, officer.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia: 那你的那个手链呢
Lucia: What about your bracelet?
Jake: 那你的那个手链在杭州可以能找到
Jake: Your bracelet might be found in Hangzhou.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure: 你怎么知道我过一段要去杭州
Shure: How did you know I'm going to Hangzhou soon?
Jake: 那你去找找
Jake: Then you go and check it out.
Lucia: lower your voices keep travel w w choices
Lucia: Lower your voices, keep travel choices in mind.
Lucia: a check we got mister lafaye her rock lance a lot
Lucia: A check, we got Mr. Lafaye and her rock Lance a lot.
Jake: 先录一段
Jake: Let's record a segment first.
Alice:晚上在这应该挺舒服
Alice: It should be quite comfortable here at night.
Alice:晚上逛公园很舒服
Alice: Strolling in the park at night is very pleasant.
Tasha:  哔哔
Tasha: Beep beep.
Alice:丁香
Alice: Lilac.
Jake: 贴了一个符就防虫了上面
Jake: Just paste a charm on it to keep bugs away.
Tasha:  无法从胶带上下来
Tasha: It can't get off the tape.
Jake: 哦这么好这
Jake: Oh, that's so effective.
Tasha:  然后就死在树上
Tasha: And then it dies on the tree.
Tasha:  当然你相信了吗
Tasha: Of course, do you believe it?
Jake: 我信
Jake: I believe it.
Tasha:  这棵树好恶心呀
Tasha: This tree is so disgusting.
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Tasha:  我说这个树好恶心啊
Tasha: I said this tree is so disgusting.
Alice:麻麻赖赖的
Alice: It's so slimy.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 一个墓地
Jake: A cemetery.
Jake: 虽然不知道是谁
Jake: Although I don't know whose it is.
Alice:谁埋这啊
Alice: Who's buried here?
Jake: 墓地
Jake: A cemetery.
Tasha:  墓地
Tasha: A cemetery.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:这有个坟包
Alice: There's a grave mound here.
Tasha:  哦天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Alice:这公园是不是就是为他建的
Alice: Is this park built just for him?
Tasha:  李治好像
Tasha: Seems like Li Zhi.
Jake: 不止吧刚刚好像看到别
Jake: Not only, I think I just saw another.
Jake: 的墓地好像是
Jake: Another cemetery, I think.
Alice:原来是个大墓园啊
Alice: So it's a big cemetery.
Alice:最多看看郁金香估计就
Alice: At most, we can only look at tulips.
Tasha:  哪有郁金香
Tasha: Where are the tulips?
Alice:我说这个季节
Alice: I mean, in this season.
Shure:  你好害怕
Shure: You're so scared.
Shure:  你好可怕呀
Shure: You're so scary.
Shure:  你这个就是就是就是
Shure: You just, just, just...
Jake: 为啥呀我这一棒槌下去是吧
Jake: Why? If I hit it with this club, right?
Shure:  一脸严肃
Shure: With a serious face.
Shure:  然后肩膀就这样走回
Shure: Then you walk back like this with your shoulders.
Shure:  我爬山
Shure: I'm hiking.
Jake: 来爬山这是什么山
Jake: Come on, what mountain is this?
Alice:未名山
Alice: Unnamed Mountain.
Lucia: 陡坡路华山
Lucia: Steep Slope Mount Hua.
Katrina:  情人坡
Katrina: Lover's Hill.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不知道是哪几个字有诗意的呢哈哈
Lucia: I don't know which characters are poetic, haha.
Jake: 是是是一个华山
Jake: Yes, yes, it's Mount Hua.
Jake: 简称华山
Jake: Also called Hua Mountain.
Jake: 我们在爬华山
Jake: We are climbing Mount Hua.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 华北紫丁香
Lucia: North China Lilac.
Jake: 香山哈哈哈哈嘿
Jake: Xiangshan, hahaha, hey.
Lucia: 啊肖华北紫荆肖善
Lucia: Ah, Xiao North China Redbud, Xiao Shan.
Jake: 这怎么有个小洞
Jake: How is there a small hole here?
Jake: 小门
Jake: Small door.
Lucia: 那里有个瞭望塔
Lucia: There's a lookout tower over there.
Lucia: 呃就是就是这个
Lucia: Uh, it's just, just this.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Lucia: 瞭望台本来想说瞭望台的嘴瓢啊
Lucia: Lookout tower, I meant to say lookout tower, slipped up.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 你说瞭望塔往上看
Jake: You mean look up at the lookout tower.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 习惯了
Lucia: Used to it.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 没有就是我
Lucia: No, I mean...
Lucia: 我经常看的一个作品
Lucia: I often watch a work.
Lucia: 里面有一个基地叫这个名字
Lucia: There's a base with that name in it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 这到公路了
Jake: We've reached the road.
Jake: 能开车了
Jake: We can drive now.
Jake: 这是出园了吗
Jake: Are we out of the park?
Jake: 还是啥意思
Jake: Or what does it mean?
Jake: 这小台阶挺好
Jake: This little step is nice.
Alice:梯田
Alice: Terraces.
Lucia: 哎呀我靠
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Alice:雷峰塔
Alice: Leifeng Pagoda.
Lucia: 哦原来这塔不在这里边
Lucia: Oh, so the pagoda isn't here.
Jake: 可以过去吧
Jake: Can we go over there?
Jake: 问问问
Jake: Ask, ask, ask.
Jake: 问看看
Jake: Ask and see.
Jake: 这有个地图倒是可以看看
Jake: There's a map here, we can check it out.
Jake: 哎咱在哪啊
Jake: Hey, where are we?
Alice:您的位置
Alice: Your location.
Jake: 在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Lucia: 这个有一个小星号的地方
Lucia: It's the place with a little star.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one?
Lucia: 您在这里
Lucia: You're here.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：好热啊
Others: It's so hot.
其他人：我再遇到一个售货机我一定要买那个投币饮料
Others: If I see another vending machine, I definitely need to get a drink from it.
其他人：我刚刚路过一个就看到了好想买
Others: I just passed by one and really wanted to buy something.
Tasha:  我刚刚想买但你们都走远了
Tasha: I wanted to buy something earlier, but you all walked away.
Katrina:  什么东西啊
Katrina: What drink?
其他人： 就是售货机里有一个饮料
Others: The drink in the vending machine.
其他人：我还挺想买的哦哦哦
Others: I really want to buy it, oh oh oh.
Tasha:  我刚刚看你想买你们都走了
Tasha: I saw you wanted to buy it, but you all left.
Tasha:  然后我在那
Tasha: So I stayed there.
Lucia: 哪里
Lucia: Where?
Jake: 哦售货机
Jake: Oh, the vending machine.
其他人：下次再遇到我就买
Others: Next time I see it, I'll buy it.
Jake: 好一会转
Jake: Okay, let's go around.
Jake: 转到最后的这个地方
Jake: Walk to the last spot.
Jake: 然后再多走一段
Jake: Then walk a bit more.
Shure:  我只想要瓶水
Shure: I just want a bottle of water.
Tasha:  那个桃子饮料汁
Tasha: That peach juice drink.
Tasha:  我当时在想他是冰的还是常温的
Tasha: I was thinking if it was cold or room temperature.
Jake: 游客中心是吗
Jake: Is it the visitor center?
Jake: 还是会有卖的
Jake: They should be selling it.
Tasha:  然后我就在那等了半天
Tasha: I waited there for a long time.
Tasha:  然后我开始人脸识别发现识别不上
Tasha: Then I tried face recognition, but it didn't work.
Jake: 卖水的地方
Jake: A place that sells water.
Lucia: 好像是一个
Lucia: Seems like it.
Tasha:  然后开始拿支付宝
Tasha: Then start using Alipay.
Lucia: 他们说是一个
Lucia: They said it’s a...
Lucia: 那个自动售货机
Lucia: ...that vending machine.
Tasha:  我发现你们已经走了
Tasha: I realized you guys had already left.
Katrina:  你在哪呢
Katrina: Where are you?
其他人：牡丹台
Others: At the Peony Platform.
Katrina:  还是这这吧
Katrina: Let's stay here.
Jake: 可能是西边
Jake: Maybe it's on the west side.
Jake: 这边像这边像一点
Jake: This side looks more like it.
Katrina:  是一个是这样
Katrina: Yeah, something like this.
Katrina:  我们是这样子过来的
Katrina: We came from this direction.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Katrina:  嗯就是从这
Katrina: Yeah, just from here.
Katrina:  那我们转一会就进去了
Katrina: We’ll go around a bit and then enter.
Katrina:  差不多在这个位置
Katrina: It’s roughly in this area.
Lucia: 所以这俩确实是一个公园
Lucia: So these two are actually one park.
Lucia: 只不过有一个北关大道
Lucia: It’s just that North Gate Avenue...
Lucia: 把他们俩隔开了
Lucia: ...separates them.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina:  那能出去吗
Katrina: Can we get out?
Jake: 这出去是这是吗
Jake: Is this the exit here?
Jake: 这是啥玩意
Jake: What is this thing?
Jake: 啥也不是
Jake: It's nothing.
Jake: 20号是谁
Jake: Who is number 20?
Alice:堤路
Alice: Di Lu.
Lucia:（歌词） 啊你是我所图的那么那么
Lucia: (Lyrics) Ah, you are what I desire, so so...
Shure:  退的话可以补查一下
Shure: If you return, you can check it again.
Tasha:  服从
Tasha: Follow.
Katrina:  let's go
Katrina: Let’s go.
Lucia: 好热呀
Lucia: It’s so hot.
Tasha:  好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Oh, yeah.
Tasha:  服从蝴蝶开会
Tasha: Follow the butterfly meeting.
Lucia: 蝴蝶开会哈哈
Lucia: Butterfly meeting, haha.
Tasha:  走开这里是蝴蝶的盛宴哈哈哈
Tasha: Move aside, this is a butterfly feast, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 我们去买水吧
Jake: Let’s go buy some water.
Tasha:  好呀
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 买到就是绕到入口的地方
Jake: We’ll buy it at the entrance area.
Tasha:  刚刚你们没看到我的那个地方
Tasha: You guys didn’t see the place where I was just now.
Lucia: 蝴蝶诱捕器哈哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哈蝴蝶应该怎么抓呀
Jake: Hahaha, how do you catch a butterfly?
Jake: 拿网抓是吧
Jake: With a net, right?
Lucia: 啊没有
Lucia: Ah, no.
Jake: 没有我现在
Jake: No? But now...
Lucia: 我们是在说怎么形容
Lucia: We're talking about how to describe it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈这个是蝴蝶诱捕器
Jake: Haha, this is the butterfly trap.
Lucia: 对对对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
Jake: 你们就过来了是吧
Jake: So you all just came over, huh?
Lucia: 我们三个是蝴蝶
Lucia: We three are butterflies.
Lucia: 这是诱捕器
Lucia: This is the trap.
Jake: oh
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 走吧我们绕回去
Jake: Let's go, let's loop back.
Tasha:  今天怎么不穿绿色
Tasha: Why aren't you wearing green today?
Tasha:  你已经被踢出我们蝴蝶工会了
Tasha: You've been kicked out of our butterfly guild.
Lucia: 哦这样啊
Lucia: Oh, really?
Tasha:  哈哈哈我还有
Tasha: Hahaha, I still have...
Jake: 我还有我还有一个裤子是绿色
Jake: I still have, I have green pants.
Lucia: 今天好像没
Lucia: Seems like not today.
Lucia: 这次出来好像没带绿衣服
Lucia: Didn't bring any green clothes this time.
Lucia: 早知道应该带一条绿裙子
Lucia: Should've brought a green dress.
Jake: 蝴蝶有绿色的吗
Jake: Are there any green butterflies?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 嗯好像不太有
Jake: Hmm, doesn't seem like there are.
Lucia: 好像不太有
Lucia: Doesn't seem like there are.
Tasha:  是那个穿着一身绿裙子啊
Tasha: It's the one wearing a green dress.
Jake: 精品蝴蝶
Jake: Premium butterfly.
Lucia: 对对那个小人是绿色的
Lucia: Yeah, that little figure is green.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 小人身边那蝴蝶好像也还真是绿色的
Lucia: The butterfly next to the little figure is green too.
其他人：是的
Others: Yes.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:官方好像每个人格都给出来三个形象
Alice: The official seems to have given each character three images.
其他人：哦对一个男的一个女的嗯还有
Others: Oh yeah, one male, one female, and...
Tasha:  还有个什么
Tasha: What's the other one?
Alice:知道但是呃
Alice: I know but, uh...
Lucia: 还有一个中性形象就是
Lucia: The other one is a neutral image.
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha:  还有男蝴蝶
Tasha: And a male butterfly.
Tasha:  就是跟我们穿的是不一样的是吧
Tasha: So, it's different from what we wear, right?
Alice:啊是的
Alice: Yes, it is.
Lucia: 对就是他的形象会有变化
Lucia: Yeah, his image will change.
Lucia: 但是代表的都是这个人格
Lucia: But it still represents the same personality.
Alice:就平时看见EFP竟然是个女的形象
Alice: Usually, when you see EFP, it's a female image.
Alice:我一直以为是个
Alice: I always thought it was...
Alice:像不像男孩
Alice: Does it look like a boy?
Lucia: 哦这样啊
Lucia: Oh, really?
Alice:就快乐小狗好像是女的
Alice: The Happy Puppy seems to be female.
Alice:就给出来的
Alice: Just the one they provided.
Alice:比较通用的
Alice: It's more universal.
Tasha:  那那你的快乐小狗是男的吗
Tasha: So, is your Happy Puppy male?
Jake: 啊这个也分吗
Jake: Oh, does it matter?
Alice:就是官方是给出来三个形象的
Alice: They officially provided three images.
Alice:一般只就是我们平时用的只
Alice: The one we usually use is just...
Jake: 哦还有
Jake: Oh, there are more?
Alice:一个是典型的形象
Alice: One is the typical image.
Jake: 型的形象
Jake: The typical image.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Lucia: 呃不是INTP
Lucia: 是药水是做实验的那个
Lucia: It's the potion used for experiments.
Alice:PG是小老头
Alice: PG is the little old man.
Lucia: 啊对对
Lucia: Oh, right, right.
Alice:ESTJ是尺节尺子
Alice: ESTJ is a measuring stick.
Lucia: ESTJ我朋友里好像都没有ESTJ
Lucia: I don't think any of my friends are ESTJ.
Katrina:  他上次不是说没有s吗
Katrina: Didn't he say there are no S's?
Katrina:  因为因为我是这两天才变成了s
Katrina: Because I only recently became an S.
Katrina:  不知道为什么变成
Katrina: I don't know why I changed.
Katrina:  我本来是ENT
Katrina: I was originally ENT.
Lucia: （歌词）don't see sulapri my four party yeah
Lucia: (Lyrics) don't see sulapri my four party yeah
Jake: 啊你怎么突然变成了s
Jake: How did you suddenly become an S?
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No...
Katrina:  就是好像在就是来北京前一天测的
Katrina: It was like the day before I came to Beijing.
Jake: 来北京突然变异了
Jake: You mutated when you came to Beijing.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 你看为什么大家加入你的team都会变
Lucia: See, why does everyone who joins your team change?
Jake: 好吃的吗
Jake: Is it delicious?
Lucia: 就是本来你说紫藤和那个谢斌竹
Lucia: Originally, you said Zitong and Xie Binzhu...
Lucia: 都是换了
Lucia: They both changed.
Lucia: 换了发型
Lucia: They changed their hairstyles.
Jake: 噢真的吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 然后然后现在那个
Lucia: And now, and now that...
Jake: 噢OK OK OK
Jake: Oh, OK OK OK.
Lucia: 哈哈又有人从n变成了s
Lucia: Haha, someone just changed from N to S.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  对我刚开始没嗯
Katrina: Yeah, at first, I didn't, um...
Lucia: 雨轩真的从n变成了s吗
Lucia: Did Yuxuan really change from N to S?
Jake: 你们有一个人从屁变成借我导致
Jake: One of you changed from a P to borrow from me, causing...
Jake: 能理解哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: I get it, hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 实话说我这两天已经有点想要变成g
Lucia: Honestly, these past two days, I've been wanting to turn into a G.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha:  因为整个组织的无纪律性
Tasha: Because of the lack of discipline in the whole organization.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 不过也挺好的
Lucia: But it's also pretty good.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我喜欢一些随机事件发生
Lucia: I like it when some random events happen.
Lucia: 就本质上还是很p
Lucia: It's basically still very P.
Jake: 这个太这个太P了
Jake: This is too, this is too P.
Jake: 这个太p了
Jake: This is too P.
Lucia: 我觉得我大部分的朋友都是NP
Lucia: I think most of my friends are NP.
Tasha:  what is this
Tasha: What is this?
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Lucia: 也有J人
Lucia: 但是少一些
Lucia: But fewer of them.
Lucia: 但是ESTJ这个组合好像
Lucia: But this ESTJ combination seems...
Alice:看到就想逃
Alice: Makes me want to run away.
Lucia: 好像在我的小伙伴里就关系很好
Lucia: It seems that in my group, we get along really well.
Lucia: 就是好到大家互相
Lucia: Like, so well that everyone...
Lucia: 这种MBTA类型的里面好像没有
Lucia: Within this MBTA type, it seems there's none.
Katrina:  但是我闺蜜全是哀人好神奇
Katrina: But all my besties are introverts, it's so amazing.
Katrina:  就是我跟哀人能建立那种长期的关系
Katrina: I mean, I can build long-term relationships with introverts.
Shure:  因为你刚才说你说完这个我感觉
Shure: Because you just said, after you said it, I feel...
Lucia: （歌词）to do
Lucia: (lyrics) to do
Lucia: （歌词）i don't see soon i pray my four Polly yeah
Lucia: (lyrics) I don't see soon, I pray my four Polly, yeah.
Jake: 好多中指
Jake: So many middle fingers.
Katrina:  就是现n是长远
Katrina: So N is long-term.
Katrina:  s是现误实
Katrina: S is present, practical.
Lucia: 哇好热
Lucia: Wow, it's so hot.
Katrina:  是不是往这走
Katrina: Should we move this way?
Shure:  想和你谈论宇宙和天空
Shure: I want to talk about the universe and the sky with you.
Shure: 往哪边走
Shure: Which way should we go?
Katrina:  反正大体方向应该是往这吧
Katrina: Anyway, the general direction should be this way, right?
Lucia: 我随机选一条路吧哈哈
Lucia: I'll just randomly pick a path, haha.
Jake: 好好我们听j的
Jake: Alright, alright, we'll follow J's lead.
Shure:  来来石头剪刀布
Shure: Come on, let's do rock-paper-scissors.
Shure:  你赢了就往那边走好吧
Shure: If you win, we'll go that way, okay?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah?
Lucia: 啊我们要分分组走了吗哦OK OK
Lucia: Ah, are we splitting up to walk? Oh, OK OK.
Jake: 没有他们在选路
Jake: No, they're just choosing a path.
Jake: 他们做历史的抉择
Jake: They're making a historical decision.
Lucia: 历史的抉择
Lucia: A historical decision?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice:历史的分岔路口
Alice: A historical crossroads.
Jake: 走左还是走右啊
Jake: Go left or go right?
Lucia: 啊哈你这有别的意思吗
Lucia: Aha, do you mean something else by that?
Jake: 没有别的意思哈哈哈
Jake: No other meaning, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈这段是不是要剪掉啊
Lucia: Haha, should we cut this part out?
Shure:  你不要瞎问
Shure: Don't ask random questions.
Lucia: 这不要瞎问
Lucia: Don't ask random questions.
Tasha:  什么叫左左还是左右
Tasha: What do you mean by left-left or left-right?
Shure: 这些放到文本里没有问题
Shure: There's no problem putting this in the script.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 对对确实确实
Lucia: Yes, yes, indeed.
Katrina:  然后现在就是
Katrina: And now it's like...
Tasha:  什么叫左左还是左右
Tasha: What do you mean by left-left or left-right?
Jake: 没有什么意思就是左
Jake: It doesn't mean anything, just left.
Jake: 向左转还是向右转
Jake: Turn left or turn right.
Shure: 你是在认真的发问是吗
Shure: Are you seriously asking?
Tasha:  对我我没有听懂这个梗
Tasha: Yes, I didn't get the joke.
Lucia: 其实也没事
Lucia: Actually, it's fine.
Lucia: 这是现在的那个啥也很常见的
Lucia: It's quite common nowadays.
Lucia: 也不一定非得有什么
Lucia: It doesn't necessarily have to mean anything.
Shure:  在那个时期
Shure: At that time...
Jake: 在那个时期可能就剪刀石头布
Jake: At that time, maybe it was just rock-paper-scissors.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 一定要再多加两两多补两刀吗
Lucia: Do you really need to add a couple more cuts?
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 就是就是一分钟之前
Jake: Just like a minute ago.
Lucia: 对对对对是这样的
Lucia: Yes, yes, that's how it is.
Jake: 没有别的意思
Jake: No other meaning.
Jake: 对对因为很难选嘛
Jake: Yeah, yeah, because it's hard to choose.
Lucia: 因为现在没岔路了
Lucia: Because there's no fork in the road now.
Tasha:  好科普一下
Tasha: Let's get some science facts.
Jake: 你在录吧
Jake: Are you recording?
Jake: 我看看你的灯
Jake: Let me check your light.
Jake: 哦确实外面看不太清
Jake: Oh, it's indeed hard to see from outside.
Jake: 但是得看一看好的
Jake: But we need to take a good look.
Tasha:  都在录
Tasha: Everything's recording.
Shure:  我斜斜的往上看一眼就能看到
Shure: I can see it if I look up sideways.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice:我这个好像红色的灯
Alice: Mine seems to have a red light.
Jake: 哦那你你看一下
Jake: Oh, then take a look.
Jake: 是不是快没电了还是怎么的
Jake: Is it almost out of battery or what?
Lucia: 亮好像是还亮着的
Lucia: The light seems to be on.
Jake: 对红的
Jake: Yeah, it's red.
Jake: 要不就是过热要不就是它过热
Jake: Either it's overheating or it's overheating.
Jake: 它会报警
Jake: It'll give an alarm.
Alice:这是有点热了 100%的电
Alice: It's a bit hot, 100% battery.
Lucia: 我手机倒是有点过热
Lucia: My phone is a bit overheated.
Lucia: 我手机电池不行了
Lucia: My phone battery is dying.
Lucia: 现在没电
Lucia: No power now.
Jake: 100%的电你插电呢是吧
Jake: 100% battery, you're plugged in, right?
Alice:yes我一直在充
Alice: Yes, I've been charging it all the time.
Tasha:  我们用了这么久还这么多电
Tasha: We've used it for so long and still have so much battery.
Jake: 他插电了
Jake: It's plugged in.
Alice:因为我在一直充电
Alice: Because I've been charging it all the time.
Jake: 那就合理
Jake: That makes sense.
Jake: 那就是过热
Jake: It's overheating.
Jake: 应该在阴凉地多走一走
Jake: We should walk in the shade more.
Jake: 降降温
Jake: Cool it down.
Alice:有点烫烫的嘞
Alice: It's a bit hot.
Jake: 降降温
Jake: Cool it down.
Alice:小蝴蝶
Alice: Little butterfly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:被圆了
Alice: It's rounded off.
Shure:  有人要滚一圈吗
Shure: Anyone want to roll a bit?
其他人：他要滚下去
Others: He's going to roll down.
其他人：你的眼镜可那什么了还是算了吧
Others: Your glasses are really something, better not.
Shure:  算了吧
Shure: Better not.
Jake: 算了
Jake: Forget it.
Lucia: 为什么要从这诡异起来
Lucia: Why is it getting weird from here?
Jake: 等不录的话你可以滚下去
Jake: If you don't record, you can get out.
其他人：因为草坪可能舒服
Katrina:  想滚
Katrina: I want to roll.
Shure:  我说眼镜看好我我给你
Shure: I'm saying, watch my glasses, I'll give them to you.
Lucia: 你把眼镜放到这录着你自己滚下去
Lucia: Put your glasses here, record yourself, and then roll down.
Shure:  算了别污染数据集了
Shure: Forget it, don't mess up the dataset.
Lucia: 然后他
Lucia: And then he...
Shure:  然后你你的行动方式有一个是滚
Shure: Then your way of moving includes rolling.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:请你圆润的滚开
Alice: Please roll away smoothly.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Jake: 就是他
Jake: That's him.
Lucia: 这是早早期人类撒欢的珍贵记录
Lucia: This is a precious record of early humans frolicking.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake: 就是从此以后就是
Jake: From now on, it's like...
Jake: 呃如果一个人想到那边
Jake: If someone thinks about it...
Jake: 然后就会Rick man的一个滚下去的做法
Jake: Then Rick man's way is to roll down.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈这样效
Jake: Hahaha, it's effective.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 率更高哈哈哈
Jake: Higher success rate, hahaha.
Lucia: 这是人工智障吧这是
Lucia: Is this artificial stupidity?
Jake: 人工智障那就是
Jake: Artificial stupidity, that's...
Shure:  因为你看咱们刚才走了一个陡坡
Shure: Because, you see, we just walked a steep slope.
Shure:  然后咱们走的时间可能就是很慢
Shure: And the time we took was really slow.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  这条路呢
Shure: This path...
Shure:  我从这到那个下坡滚这时间更快了
Shure: If I roll down this slope, the time will be faster.
Lucia: 啊所以
Lucia: Ah, so...
Lucia: 当给出的指令是计算最快路线的时候
Lucia: When the instruction is to calculate the fastest route...
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 就会滚
Lucia: It rolls.
Shure:  一直以为
Shure: Always thought...
Tasha:  啊就会走这里
Tasha: Ah, so it goes here.
Tasha:  走超进道了
Tasha: Taking a shortcut.
Jake: 哎抄近道然后走的话晚上他就给我
Jake: Yeah, taking a shortcut, then at night, he gives me...
Alice:高德地图不管我能不能过去
Alice: Gaode Map doesn't care if I can pass.
Alice:反正他就给我一个穿墙的选项
Alice: Anyway, he just gave me an option to walk through walls.
Alice:是不是也是这样的
Alice: Is it the same for you?
Shure:  有可能
Shure: Possibly.
Jake: 穿墙 这不行
Jake: Walking through walls? That's not gonna work.
Lucia: 那个应该是他数据没及时更新
Lucia: Maybe his data wasn't updated in time.
Lucia: 就是他不知道哪封 上
Lucia: He didn't know which...
Jake: 对这是不够智能
Jake: Yeah, it's not smart enough.
Jake: 就是滚下去是可以实现的
Jake: Rolling down is doable.
Jake: 穿墙是不可实现的
Jake: But walking through walls isn't.
Lucia: 你怎么知道
Lucia: How do you know?
Lucia: 他不是想让你把墙砸掉啊
Lucia: He doesn't want you to break the wall, does he?
Jake: 哈哈哦哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, oh hahaha.
Alice:不管我的死活是吧哈哈哈
Alice: Doesn't care if I live or die, right? Haha.
Alice:哎在这浇花很方便
Alice: Hey, watering plants here is so convenient.
Alice:直接往这一冲
Alice: Just pour it right here.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yep.
Alice:水顺着就流下去了
Alice: The water just flows down.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Exactly.
Shure:  这就是梯田是吗
Shure: Is this a terrace?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yep.
Alice:水好亮
Alice: The water is so shiny.
Tasha:  波光粼粼
Tasha: It's sparkling.
Alice:粼粼
Alice: Sparkling.
Lucia: 我们现在是要玩飞花令了吗哈哈
Lucia: Are we going to play the "Flying Flower Order" game now? Haha.
Jake: 来看你们表演
Jake: Let's see you perform.
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 就是你们刚才那个波光粼粼
Lucia: Just that sparkling you mentioned...
Lucia: 我突然想起来昨
Lucia: Reminded me of...
Lucia: 天的成语接龙
Lucia: Yesterday's idiom game.
Lucia: 然后就想起来废话令那个提案
Lucia: And then I remembered the nonsense proposal.
Alice:我先来
Alice: I'll go first.
Shure: 啊这是球队的帽子
Shure: Ah, this is a team hat.
Lucia: 对对巴萨了
Lucia: Yeah, it's from Barça.
Jake: 这什么球队
Jake: What team is this?
Shure: 巴萨的
Shure: It's Barça's.
Jake: 看一下哦
Jake: Let me see.
Jake: 阿塞尔的
Jake: It's from Arsenal.
Lucia: 真的在真的在
Lucia: It's real, it's real.
Lucia: 那个诺坎普买的哈哈
Lucia: Bought it at the Camp Nou. Haha.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Alice:成语接龙
Alice: Idiom relay
Lucia: 我现在不是不是巴萨的球迷了
Lucia: I'm no longer a Barca fan now.
Lucia: 也不是不是
Lucia: Not, not anymore.
Lucia: 就是还没有到路转不是
Lucia: I haven't completely turned away yet.
Lucia: 也没有到粉转黑的程度
Lucia: But I'm not a die-hard fan anymore.
Lucia: 就粉转路吧
Lucia: Just a casual fan now.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 因为这两年管理太混乱了
Lucia: Because the management has been too chaotic these past two years.
Jake: OK
Jake: Got it.
Alice:为所欲为
Alice: Do whatever you want.
Lucia: 我正在试图找一个新球队
Lucia: I'm trying to find a new team.
Lucia: 现在目前的备选是阿森纳
Lucia: Currently considering Arsenal.
Jake: 阿森纳大炮
Jake: Arsenal cannons.
Alice:维他命c也能是成语吗
Alice: Can vitamin C be an idiom?
Jake: 他们在射箭嘛
Jake: They're shooting arrows, right?
Jake: 有点厉害
Jake: Pretty impressive.
Lucia: everywhere
Lucia: Everywhere.
Jake: 前面那两位
Jake: Those two in front.
Lucia: 啊 对 像
Lucia: Ah, yes, like that.
Lucia: 这个衬衣看起来好舒服呀
Lucia: This shirt looks so comfortable.
Tasha:  随便买的
Tasha: Just bought it casually.
Jake: 但前面是有卖东西的地方吗
Jake: But is there a place that sells things in front?
Tasha:  社区便利店
Tasha: Community convenience store.
Jake: 像吗这个像吗
Jake: Does it look like this?
Jake: 社区便利店确实是
Jake: Community convenience stores really are.
Tasha:  便民
Tasha: Convenient.
Shure:  但是他有没有可能在墙那里面呢
Shure: But could it possibly be inside the wall?
Tasha:  让他伸出来
Tasha: Let it stick out.
Tasha:  爷爷给我一瓶水
Tasha: Grandpa, give me a bottle of water.
Jake: OK
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 手机连成一串
Jake: Connect the phones together.
Jake: 谢谢您哎呀
Jake: Thank you so much.
Jake: 对这个
Jake: For this.
Shure:  这
Shure: This.
Jake: 对啊得有一个包嘛
Jake: Yes, there should be a bag.
Katrina:  这是什么花
Katrina: What kind of flower is this?
Lucia: 哈哈哈我不会说出去的
Lucia: Haha, I won't tell.
Katrina:  这我没见过
Katrina: I've never seen this before.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 快乐吃瓜哈哈
Lucia: Enjoying the gossip, haha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice:什么鬼
Alice: What the heck
Alice:魔鬼我错过了什么
Alice: Oh my gosh, what did I miss?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 没错过是吧
Lucia: You didn't miss anything, right?
Katrina:  30度
Katrina: It's 30 degrees
Lucia: 你问微微哈哈
Lucia: Ask Tasha, haha
Tasha:  什么都没有
Tasha: Nothing at all
Tasha:  啦啦啦
Tasha: Lalala
Katrina:  我还带了加绒卫衣呢
Katrina: I even brought a fleece hoodie
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh
Jake: 这确实出不去对吧
Jake: We really can't get out, right?
Tasha:  便民空间
Tasha: Convenience space
Tasha:  里面没有便民超市
Tasha: There's no convenience store inside
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 那这个空间是干嘛的呢
Jake: So what's this space for?
Katrina:  这没有口
Katrina: There's no exit here
Katrina:  那前面是不是口啊
Katrina: Is there an exit up ahead?
Tasha:  类似于那种社区空间
Tasha: It's like a community space
Jake: 打麻将用的
Jake: For playing mahjong
Tasha:  呃也许吧
Tasha: Uh, maybe
Lucia: 还有乒乓球估计
Lucia: Probably for ping pong too
Tasha:  读书
Tasha: Reading
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha:  乒乓球
Tasha: Ping pong
Jake: 那这也
Jake: Well, this also...
Katrina:  耳朵
Katrina: Ear
Tasha:  哎但这有卖水的门口
Tasha: Hey, but there's a water-selling booth at the entrance
Lucia: 冲呀
Lucia: Let's go!
Katrina:  那好像能出去
Katrina:  出去就过来
Katrina: Go out and come back
Katrina:  应该这种修的这种道都会用
Katrina: Roads built like this are always in use
Lucia: 有被晒到
Lucia: Getting some sun
Shure:  我们的野餐
Shure: Our picnic
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Shure:  我们的野餐就是刚刚在在那个栏杆上
Shure: Our picnic was just on that railing
Lucia: 其实已经吃掉一盒了
Lucia: Actually, we already finished a box
Shure:  然后吃狮子
Shure: Then we ate a lion
Jake: 跟鱼一起吃披萨对
Jake: Eating pizza with fish, right?
Shure:  然后爆掉一个手串
Shure: And then a bracelet exploded.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  献祭它
Shure: Sacrifice it.
Lucia: 啊他说他在说我们的野餐计划
Lucia: Ah, he said he was talking about our picnic plan.
Lucia: 就是刚才和鱼一起
Lucia: It was just now with the fish.
Tasha:  生态共享
Tasha: Ecological sharing.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 你看
Lucia: Look.
Jake: 还有第二餐
Jake: There's a second meal.
Jake: 其实我们还有几个披萨
Jake: Actually, we still have a few pizzas.
Lucia: 这次喂谁呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Who are we feeding this time? Hahaha.
Tasha:  还有一盒
Tasha: There's one more box.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们还有一盒披萨
Jake: Hahaha, we still have a box of pizza.
Katrina:  被留当晚饭了
Katrina: Saved for dinner.
Lucia: 可是这里没有那个
Lucia: But there's no...
Tasha:  好像是羊肉披萨
Tasha: I think it's lamb pizza.
Katrina:  现在小龙虾还挺好吃
Katrina: The crayfish are quite tasty now.
Lucia: 没有那个海鸥耶
Lucia: There's no seagull here.
Jake: 北京竟然没有海鸥
Jake: Beijing actually has no seagulls.
Tasha:  北京为什么会有海鸥
Tasha: Why would Beijing have seagulls?
Lucia: 北京也不靠海吧好像
Lucia: Beijing isn't even by the sea, I think.
Jake: 北京
Jake: Beijing.
Katrina:  我身上穿的就是海鸥
Katrina: I'm wearing a seagull.
Tasha:  噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Tasha:  不行了
Tasha: I can't take it anymore.
Katrina:  给我
Katrina: Give it to me.
Lucia: 好晒啊
Lucia: It's so sunny.
Tasha:  又晒又热
Tasha: It's both sunny and hot.
Lucia: 不行我要两个都摘掉我就给他拿下来
Lucia: No, I'm taking both off, I'll just give them to him.
Lucia: 别掉了
Lucia: Don't drop them.
Jake: 你这身上设备挺多
Jake: You have a lot of equipment on you.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 对我带了个耳机
Lucia: Yeah, I brought headphones.
Jake: 对很赛博
Jake: Very cyber.
Lucia: 我已经为了照顾这个眼镜没有戴大
Lucia: I didn't wear the big ones to take care of these glasses.
Lucia: 戴了头戴耳机了哈哈
Lucia: So I wore the headband ones, haha.
Alice:啊可以出去
Alice: Ah, we can go out.
Tasha:  已经出去了
Tasha: Already went out.
Tasha:  都没有遇到水
Tasha: Didn't even encounter water.
Jake: 没有水
Jake: There's no water.
Tasha:  走错路了
Tasha: We took the wrong path.
Jake: 问问看吧是出哪去了
Jake: Let's ask where we are.
Jake: 看看地图吧要不
Jake: Or maybe look at the map?
Tasha:  公园就采集完毕了吗
Tasha: Are we done collecting in the park?
Jake: 诶诶诶
Jake: Eh eh eh.
Lucia: 我们走到那个塔那个那里面了吗
Lucia: Did we reach that tower or not?
Lucia: 是不是没有呀
Lucia: Maybe we didn't?
Lucia: 我我没记得
Lucia: I don't remember.
Lucia: 我有见到那个塔
Lucia: I think I saw that tower.
Jake: 我其实是在找水但是没找着
Jake: I was actually looking for water but couldn't find any.
Lucia: 啊好的吧
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 保利发展控股竟然在这里
Lucia: Poly Developments is actually here.
Alice:蜻蜓跌水
Alice: Dragonfly fell into the water.
Lucia: 这片地不会都是保利的吧
Lucia: Could all this land belong to Poly?
Jake: 我们这个路走的确实抽象了一点
Jake: We're really taking a convoluted path.
Jake: 我们在沿河走离这个公园越来越远
Jake: We're walking along the river, getting farther from the park.
Lucia: 啊哈嗯
Lucia: Ah ha, hmm.
Jake: 哈哈哈可以这就是
Jake: Hahaha, okay, this is...
Lucia: 这个是符合符合计划的吗嗯
Lucia: Is this according to the plan, huh?
Jake: 可能没有特别符合
Jake: Probably not exactly.
Lucia: 那我们怎么办
Lucia: So what do we do?
Jake: 那我们在可能绕回去吧
Jake: We might have to loop back.
Lucia: 要绕回去呢
Lucia: We need to loop back?
Lucia: 我们修正一下路线
Lucia: Let's correct our route.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:  可恶路线选错了
Tasha: Damn, we chose the wrong path.
Shure:  不行我们去超市的时候再买水
Shure: It's fine, we'll buy water at the supermarket.
Jake: 那可能有点这边真的没有水哈
Jake: That might be a good idea; there's really no water here.
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Jake: 这可是居民区的呀
Jake: This is a residential area.
Jake: 我们已经
Jake: We already...
Shure:  要走到小区里
Shure: Need to walk into the neighborhood.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  刚那便利店
Katrina: That convenience store...
Katrina:  只能从这出去再绕回去
Katrina: We can only exit here and loop back.
Jake: 对我们偏离路线偏离了一公里
Jake: Yeah, we deviated from the route by a kilometer.
Jake: 哈哈哈没有关系没有关系
Jake: Hahaha, it's alright, it's alright.
Katrina:  yeah
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure:  一定是在这年的计划中吧
Shure: This must be part of this year's plan, right?
Katrina:  yeah
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 一定有他的道理
Lucia: There must be a reason for it.
Jake: 没问题
Jake: No problem.
Alice:那我们走水路吧
Alice: Then let's take the water route.
Katrina:  在钓鱼哎
Katrina: Someone's fishing over there.
Alice:感觉那里面凉快
Alice: It feels cooler over there.
Lucia: 我们可以沿着它走
Lucia: We can walk along it.
Jake: 我们可以过个马路得了来都来了
Jake: We can cross the road since we're already here.
Alice:来都来了
Alice: Since we're already here.
Lucia: 那就我走到保利的那块地坪上去
Lucia: Then I'll walk over to the Polly's area.
Jake: 对面是不是也没有什么
Jake: There's nothing much on the other side, right?
Jake: 还是那就走水陆会
Jake: Or we could just take the water route.
Jake: 还是这边阴凉一点
Jake: It's a bit cooler on this side.
Lucia: 理论上说太阳现在是这个方向
Lucia: 所以可能都不是很阴凉
Lucia: So it might not be very cool anywhere.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Alice:我们不能游过去吗
Alice: Can't we swim across?
Jake: 可以
Jake: We can.
Lucia: yes you can我帮你保管眼睛
Lucia: Yes, you can. I'll keep your glasses safe.
Shure:  但眼镜不防水
Shure: But glasses aren't waterproof.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Alice:谁会游泳呢
Alice: Who can swim?
Lucia: 其实我会哈哈
Lucia: Actually, I can, haha.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  我小时候在这种野湖里游过
Shure: I used to swim in wild lakes like this when I was a kid.
Jake: 回头
Jake: Turn back.
Jake: 回到起点
Jake: Back to the starting point.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha:  啊什么
Tasha: Huh, what?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  回到七天院
Katrina: Back to Qitian Courtyard.
Shure: 我们可以不回从这去下一个地点
Shure: Can't we just go to the next spot from here without going back?
Katrina:  要不要先买水再回到起点
Katrina: Should we buy some water first before going back to the start?
Jake: 也可以水在这附近还是
Jake: We can. Is the water nearby or...
Katrina:  水就刚刚那个便利店
Katrina: The water's just at the convenience store we passed.
Katrina:  只是从这绕绕出去一下
Katrina: We just need to circle around a bit.
Jake: 好那绕一圈
Jake: Alright, let's take a detour.
Jake: 再绕一圈
Jake: Go around one more time.
Jake: 把小区给建了
Jake: Let's build the community.
Shure: 但是小区我们没有那什么能进吗
Shure: But we don't have access to the community, can we get in?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 脸不可以吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can't we just use our faces? Hahaha.
Jake: 咱就说要买水
Jake: Let's just say we're buying water.
Jake: 光天化日之下我们能干什么
Jake: What can we do in broad daylight?
Katrina:  应该能进去吧这边
Katrina: We should be able to get in here.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 拍VLOG吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Let's film a vlog, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哎呀干嘛
Lucia: Oh no, what are you doing?
Alice:吓死我了
Alice: You scared me to death!
Lucia: 对不起
Lucia: Sorry.
Alice:没有没有没有
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Alice:我在想事情
Alice: I was just thinking.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 在想什么呀
Lucia: What were you thinking about?
Alice:我在想我五一怎么回家
Alice: I was thinking about how to go home for Labor Day.
Alice:要不要回家
Alice: Whether I should go home or not.
Alice:你呢
Alice: What about you?
Alice:你的五一安排是什么
Alice: What's your plan for Labor Day?
Lucia: 我应该要回吧
Lucia: 我五一安排在家躺着
Lucia: My plan for Labor Day is to stay at home and lie down.
Lucia: 因为五一放假出去玩的人太多了
Lucia: Because there are too many people going out during the holiday.
Alice:对我也是
Alice: Yeah, me too.
Alice:我就在想
Alice: I was just thinking.
Alice:回家躺跟在寝室躺
Alice: Is there a big difference between lying at home and lying in the dorm?
Alice:有什么本质上特别的区别吗
Alice: Is there any essential difference?
Lucia: 回家躺可以躺的
Lucia: Lying at home, you can lie down.
Lucia: 你的床更大
Lucia: Your bed is bigger.
Alice:确实
Alice: True.
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 我看到了两个字
Jake: I saw two words.
Lucia: 哒哒哒哒
Lucia: Da da da da.
Tasha:  你眼睛睁好我看不见
Tasha: Open your eyes, I can't see.
Lucia: 这进不去耶
Lucia: We can't get in here.
Katrina:  这进不去
Katrina: We can't get in here.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Katrina:  只能在这看有没有买水的
Katrina: We can only see if there's anyone selling water here.
Jake: 带隐形眼镜的呀
Jake: Wearing contact lenses?
Jake: 有超市好强啊
Jake: There's a supermarket, so cool.
Tasha:  看见
Tasha: I see.
Lucia: 我每次放假的时候都更喜欢哈哈
Lucia: I always enjoy it more when I'm on vacation, haha.
Lucia: 家里蹲
Lucia: Stay at home.
Lucia: 因为外面人太多了除非迫不得已
Lucia: Because there are too many people outside, unless absolutely necessary.
Alice:我给你看
Alice: Let me show you.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Jake: 羽毛球
Jake: Badminton.
Alice:给你看床上
Alice: Look at the bed.
Alice:过完那天野营的四月啊
Alice: After that day of camping in April.
Lucia: 这是哪天啊
Lucia: What day was that?
Lucia: 清明节吗
Lucia: Qingming Festival?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 对妈耶
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Alice:野营的人比树还多
Alice: There were more campers than trees.
Alice:我那天快被吓死了
Alice: I was so scared that day.
Lucia: 树还多
Lucia: More trees.
Alice:但那天天还蛮好的
Alice: But the weather was quite nice that day.
Alice:我们去逛了
Alice: We went for a stroll.
Lucia: 不行
Lucia: No way.
Alice:我们去放风筝了
Alice: We flew kites.
Lucia: 妈耶
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Alice:你最近会在北京待吗
Alice: Are you staying in Beijing recently?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yep.
Lucia: 我要是在北京待我还得专门租个房子
Lucia: If I stay in Beijing, I'll have to rent a place.
Alice:那你是这个结束之后先回家还是
Alice: So after this, are you going home first or...
Lucia: 我现在是这样想的
Lucia: That's what I'm thinking now.
Lucia: 不过我也有可能需要在北京办点事情
Lucia: But I might need to handle some things in Beijing.
Lucia: 所以不是很确定
Lucia: So I'm not really sure.
Alice:有无怡宝有看到了
Alice: Do you see any Yibao water?
Jake: 呃可以报吧
Jake: Uh, can you report it?
Jake: 你们扫吧
Jake: You guys scan it.
Alice:有人喝矿泉水吗
Alice: Anyone want some mineral water?
Jake: 嗯不喝
Jake: Hmm, no thanks.
Lucia: 好多种类
Lucia: So many options.
Lucia: 我选择恐惧症犯了
Lucia: I'm having choice paralysis.
Jake: 一起付
Jake: Let's pay together.
Lucia: 我要这个
Lucia: I want this one.
Alice:好你要哪个
Alice: Okay, which one do you want?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 帮我选一个吧
Jake: Help me pick one.
Lucia: 你有选择恐惧症吗
Lucia: Do you have a fear of making choices?
Jake: 谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 这个就算了
Jake: Forget about this one.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake: 我知道我可以say no
Jake: I know I can say no.
Jake: 我不能我不知道这个吧
Jake: I can't, I don't know about this one.
Alice:这个吧
Alice: How about this one?
Jake: 这个也可以
Jake: This one works too.
Jake: 这个可以谢谢您
Jake: This one is good, thank you.
Lucia: 我觉得值得试试东鹏特饮
Lucia: I think it's worth trying Dongpeng Special Drink.
Lucia: 困了累了喝东鹏特饮
Lucia: When you're tired or sleepy, drink Dongpeng Special Drink.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 啊哎
Lucia: Ah, hey.
Lucia: 咱们的一样啊
Lucia: We have the same one!
Lucia: 你知道薇薇选的是什么
Lucia: Do you know what Tasha picked?
Lucia: 说不定我们三个都一样
Lucia: Maybe all three of us picked the same one.
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Jake: 薇薇还没选
Jake: Tasha hasn't picked yet.
其他人：静待她拿哦她没有拿这个
Others: Let's wait for her... she didn't pick this one.
Lucia: 他拿了尖叫
Lucia: She picked Jiao.
其他人：几瓶
Others: How many bottles?
其他人：123456
Others: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Lucia: 还有个这个
Lucia: And there's this one.
其他人：32一共
Others: 32 in total.
Jake: 啊扫的这么快
Jake: Wow, you scanned them so fast.
其他人：32 35
Others: 32, 35.
Jake:  OK行
Jake: Okay, got it.
Jake: 我怎么付你
Jake: How do I pay you?
Jake: 我扫这个行
Jake: Can I scan this?
其他人：行
Others: Sure.
其他人：开喝
Others: Let's drink.
Jake: 35
Jake: 35.
其他人：嗯
Others: Yeah.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 呃走
Jake: Uh, let's go.
其他人：微信收款35元
Others: WeChat payment received: 35 yuan.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Jake: 一个7新币的水
Jake: A 7-dollar water.
Jake: 哈哈哈也可以
Jake: Hahaha, it's fine.
Lucia: 这个7 金币吗
Lucia: This is 7 dollars?
Jake: 没有就是花了35嘛
Jake: No, it cost 35.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake: 相当于我买了一个七新币的水
Jake: It's like I bought a 7-dollar water.
Jake: 也不是不不常见
Jake: It's not that unusual.
Jake: 哈哈哈就是
Jake: Hahaha, just...
Shure:  怎么说下一站吗
Shure: So, where to next?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  回到起点
Katrina: Back to the start.
Katrina:  下一站去哪
Katrina: Where to next?
Katrina:  要不直接在这打车也行
Katrina: Or we could just grab a cab here.
Jake: 也行啊下一站去哪啊
Jake: Sure, where to next?
Katrina:  买东西啊
Katrina: Shopping.
Shure:  我们找找个好打车的地
Shure: Let's find a good spot for a cab.
Alice:买什么调料跟什么肉啥来着
Alice: What were we buying again? Spices and meat?
Shure:  这这应该不好打车
Shure: This place might be hard to get a cab.
Jake: 呃不好意思
Jake: Uh, sorry.
Jake: 去哪买啊
Jake: Where to buy?
Shure:  找一个大一点的
Shure: Find a bigger place.
Shure:  商超吧还是
Shure: A supermarket maybe?
Tasha:  啊我不想走
Tasha: Ah, I don't want to walk.
Alice:有没有那种什么食材
Alice: Is there a wholesale market?
Alice:批发
Alice: For ingredients?
Alice:市场那种直接带串好签的不也行吗
Alice: Somewhere that sells skewers already prepped?
Shure:  也行
Shure: That works.
Alice:碳油刷子
Alice: Charcoal, oil, brushes...
Katrina:  大超市
Katrina: A big supermarket.
Shure:  搜一搜勾人
Shure: Let's search for one.
Tasha:  嗯很凉快
Tasha: Hmm, it's quite cool.
Katrina:  这200米居然有个盒马先生
Katrina: There's a Hema Fresh 200 meters away.
Katrina:  200米居然只有
Katrina: Only 200 meters away.
Jake: 一定有点
Jake: There has to be one.
Shure:  四四四百米
Shure: Four, four hundred meters.
Katrina:  400米有个盒马先生
Katrina: 400 meters to Hema Fresh.
Jake: 走吧走
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  去盒马是吗
Katrina: Are we going to Hema?
其他人：去盒马可以把晚饭解决了
Others: Going to Hema can settle dinner.
Katrina:  那就盒马
Katrina: Then Hema it is.
Katrina:  直接买那个肉
Katrina: Let's just buy that meat.
Katrina:  然后烤肉
Katrina: And then grill it.
Jake: 还有对
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Tasha:  那还回公园吗
Tasha: Are we still going back to the park?
Jake: 不回了不回了吧
Jake: No, let's not go back.
Lucia: 会不会有点晒
Lucia: Won't it be a bit too sunny?
其他人：还好谢谢
Others: It's alright, thanks.
其他人：在这里呢
Others: Right here.
其他人：就是预防一点鱼尾纹
Others: It's just to prevent some crow's feet.
其他人：就一直眯眼的话就长鱼尾纹哦
Others: If you squint a lot, you'll get crow's feet.
其他人：所以戴墨镜就要
Others: So you need to wear sunglasses.
Lucia: 把墨镜叠戴到这个上面哈哈哈
Lucia: Stack the sunglasses on top of this one, haha.
Lucia: 拿了一个外套
Lucia: I got a jacket.
Lucia: 感觉好像也不是很能穿的上
Lucia: It feels like I won't really need it.
Lucia: 还挺热的
Lucia: It's quite hot.
其他人：刚跟他们说
Others: Just told them.
其他人：前两天都没有这种烈日下徒步的环节
Others: The past few days didn't have this walking under the scorching sun part.
其他人：今天我一来就有了
Others: Today, as soon as I came, there is.
Lucia: 我应该打打个伞
Lucia: I should have brought an umbrella.
Lucia: 我其实带了一把伞在箱子里
Lucia: Actually, I did bring one, it's in my suitcase.
其他人烧烤披萨
Others: Barbecue pizza.
Lucia: 我们是今天晚上烤吗
Lucia: Are we grilling tonight?
其他人：好像是
Others: Seems like it.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
其他人：然后今天烤一次最后一天也要考一次
Others: We're grilling tonight and on the last day too.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
其他人：那可没有赶上好时候
Others: Then you didn't come at the best time.
Lucia: 就是谢斌竹
Lucia: It's Xie Bin Zhu.
其他人： 他们也挺想吃烧烤的然后没赶上
Others: They really wanted barbecue too, but missed it.
其他人：没办法了
Others: Nothing we can do.
Lucia: 他们今天有课是吗
Lucia: Do they have classes today?
其他人：我们交替着呢啊
Others: We're taking turns.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
其他人：因为过来实在是很远
Others: Because it's really far to come over.
其他人：然后我今天来的话他们就不用来了
Others: So if I come today, they don't have to.
Lucia: 你们学校是大概在哪哪一站来着
Lucia: Where is your school located, which station?
其他人：我们超远的
Others: It's super far.
其他人：就是我想想啊在哪一站
Other: Let me think, which station is it?
其他人： 还就是西土城哦哦
Other: Oh, it's Xitucheng, oh.
Lucia: 哦哦
Lucia: Oh, oh.
其他人： 牡丹园那边很远
Other: Mudanyuan is really far.
Lucia: 确实哎
Lucia: It really is.
Lucia: 不过我觉得从这过来从就是到这
Lucia: But I think coming from here to there...
Lucia: 从哪都挺远的
Lucia: It's pretty far from anywhere.
其他人：嗯对
Other: Yeah, true.
Lucia: 那你是坐地铁来的还是你开车来的呀
Lucia: Did you come by subway or did you drive?
其他人：我坐地铁来的
Other: I took the subway.
Jake: 大家想想大家想想有没有要要报案的
Jake: Everyone think, think if anyone needs to report.
Jake: 顺便就哈哈哈哈
Jake: By the way, hahaha.
Jake: 啊不用不用
Jake: Ah, no need, no need.
Jake: 逛逛商场
Jake: Just wander around the mall.
Alice:风云再起
Alice: Fengyun Zaiqi.
Jake: 这个商场档次如何
Jake: How is this mall's quality?
Tasha:  那我们要不要去看一下风云再起
Tasha: Should we go check out Fengyun Zaiqi?
Alice:你要抓娃娃
Alice: You want to catch dolls?
Jake: 风云再起是什么
Jake: What's Fengyun Zaiqi?
Lucia: 呃呃看起来像健身俱乐部
Lucia: Uh, uh, looks like a fitness club.
Alice:呃电
Alice: Uh, arcade.
Tasha:  抓娃娃了嗯
Tasha: Catch dolls, yeah.
Jake: 行啊那抓会啊
Jake: Alright, then let's catch some.
Alice:不是是那种打电动的
Alice: No, it's one of those arcade places.
Lucia: 可以穿吗哈
Lucia: Can you wear it, haha?
Jake: 抓走
Jake: Let's go catch.
Tasha:  走
Tasha: Let's go.
Shure: 不行
Shure: No way.
Tasha:  什么不行
Tasha: What do you mean no way?
Jake: 什么不行
Jake: What no way?
Lucia: 哈什么不行
Lucia: Haha, what no way?
Jake: 都行都行
Jake: Everything's fine.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:他们在另一个话题
Alice: They're on a different topic.
Jake: 哦什么不行啊
Jake: Oh, what do you mean no way?
Tasha:  哦哈
Tasha: Oh, haha.
Jake: 什么不行
Jake: What no way?
Tasha:  不知道我以为风云再起不行
Tasha: I don't know, I thought Fengyun Zaiqi wasn't possible.
Tasha:  那他就别玩哈哈
Tasha: Then he shouldn't play, haha.
Jake: 风云再起为啥不行
Jake: Why not Fengyun Zaiqi?
Lucia: 我觉得看起来像啊
Lucia: I think it looks like it.
Lucia: 那有可能是游戏厅旁边写了一个游戏
Lucia: Maybe there's a game written next to the arcade.
Alice:我的儿子怎么在这
Alice: Why is my son here?
Jake: 哦你的儿子哦
Jake: Oh, your son?
Alice:旅行青蛙
Alice: Traveling Frog.
Lucia: 哦蛙儿子
Lucia: Oh, frog son.
Alice:我的儿子怎么在这
Alice: Why is my son here?
Lucia: 他旅行到这里了
Lucia: He traveled here.
Tasha:  适配是吗
Tasha: Does it fit?
Jake: 哈哈颜色挺到位是吧
Jake: Haha, the color matches well, right?
Lucia: 这还有一个青蛙
Lucia: There's another frog here.
Tasha:  让AI采集一下
Tasha: Let AI collect it.
Tasha:  破解一下娃娃机的秘密
Tasha: Let's crack the secret of the claw machine.
Lucia: 那个好像是编好程的
Lucia: That seems to be pre-programmed.
Lucia: 就是他
Lucia: It's like...
Lucia: 隔几次就会有一次抓得比较紧的时候
Lucia: Every few times it grabs tighter.
Jake: 哎我们先
Jake: Hey, let's...
Jake: 我我们我们先在商场里边整点活吧
Jake: Let's do something in the mall first.
Jake: 先晃悠晃悠
Jake: Let's wander around.
Jake: 然后再买东西再提走对
Jake: Then we'll buy stuff and leave, right?
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Sure.
Shure:  我们去小米买点电电池哈哈哈
Shure: Let's go to Xiaomi to buy some batteries, haha.
Lucia: 哦好特卖
Lucia: Oh, special sale.
Katrina:  我最喜欢买
Katrina: I love buying.
Katrina:  好特卖好特卖好特卖好特卖
Katrina: Special sale, special sale, special sale, special sale.
Lucia: 对对对因为比较便宜
Lucia: Yes, yes, because it's cheaper.
Jake: 好好特卖是什么
Jake: What's special sale?
Katrina:  便宜货呵呵呵
Katrina: Cheap stuff, hehe.
Lucia: 那个特价店对对对
Lucia: That discount store, right, right.
Jake: 哦哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Katrina:  就是他都是那种临期的
Katrina: They sell near-expiry products.
Jake: 等等会等会
Jake: Wait, wait.
Katrina:  但是对于我们就
Katrina: But for us...
Jake: 我我们好像还没对齐
Jake: We seem to be not aligned yet.
Jake: 现在甚至现在
Jake: Even now...
Jake: 对一下把把把他叫过来来来来
Jake: Let's align and call him over, come on, come on.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Shure:  哦我们出发的时候忘看这个
Shure: Oh, we forgot to check this when we left.
Jake: 对没看这个东西对好
Jake: Right, didn't check this, okay.
Jake: 3:47 行
Jake: 3:47, alright.
Katrina:  那我要去买包卫生巾
Katrina: Then I need to go buy some sanitary pads.
Lucia: 太吵了我需要抓住一个人哈哈
Lucia: It's too noisy, I need to grab someone, haha.
其他人：一个人的时候是不会来玩这些的
Others: You wouldn't play these alone.
Lucia: 对我也不太会
Lucia: Yeah, I probably wouldn't either.
Lucia: 只有跟小伙伴一起会
Lucia: Only with friends.
Lucia: 而且其实我每次进来都觉得很吵
Lucia: And actually, every time I come in, I find it really noisy.
Lucia: 虽然有一些还挺好玩的
Lucia: Although some things are quite fun.
Lucia: 他居然挂在外面
Lucia: He's actually hanging outside.
Lucia: 顺手拿出我的魔法剪刀
Lucia: I casually pull out my magic scissors.
Lucia: 哈哈魔法剪刀
Lucia: Haha, magic scissors!
Jake: 抓一次多少钱
Jake: How much for one try?
Lucia: 现在可能两一般两块钱吧好像
Lucia: Now maybe two, usually around two yuan, I think.
Lucia: 反正感觉他这玩意在涨价所以就
Lucia: Anyway, it feels like it's getting more expensive, so...
Jake: 哦哦看看看看看看
Jake: Oh, oh, let's see, let's see.
Katrina:  3块钱一次
Katrina: 3 yuan per try.
其他人：抓一次 3块钱
Others: 3 yuan per try.
Lucia: 3都3块钱了
Lucia: It's up to 3 yuan now?
Lucia: 北京已经这个行情了吗
Lucia: Is that the rate in Beijing now?
Jake: 这么贵
Jake: So expensive.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Tasha:  觉得在团购上买会不会便宜
Tasha: Do you think it's cheaper to buy in bulk?
Jake: 100个币是什么意思
Jake: What does 100 coins mean?
Jake: 100个币抓几次
Jake: How many tries for 100 coins?
Alice:他们有的是3个币
Alice: Some cost 3 coins.
Lucia: 除以三三个币
Lucia: Divide by three, so three coins.
Tasha:  可能抓30次吧
Tasha: Maybe 30 tries.
Alice:有的5个币
Alice: Some cost 5 coins.
Alice:这种抓一次
Alice: One try for those.
Tasha:  30次吧
Tasha: Probably 30 tries.
Shure:  3个币左右
Shure: Around 3 coins.
Lucia: 30次大概
Lucia: About 30 tries.
Jake: 那我100个币你们你们自由分配
Jake: Then I'll give you 100 coins, you guys can distribute them as you like.
Shure:  就位好
Shure: Ready.
Katrina:  好吧那就微信购
Katrina: Alright, let's buy through WeChat then.
Jake: 好吧好行
Jake: Okay, sounds good.
Katrina:  是不是便宜点
Katrina: Is it cheaper?
Shure:  呼呼
Shure: Haha.
Lucia: 看一下美团有吗
Lucia: Check if Meituan has it.
Jake: 怎么哦好行
Jake: Oh, okay, sounds good.
Tasha:  我也这么觉得的
Tasha: I think so too.
Lucia: 那个微信购币好像89100币
Lucia: That WeChat coin purchase seems to be 89100 coins.
Katrina:  耶老板万岁哈哈
Katrina: Yay, long live the boss, haha!
Shure:  若每人夸一句杨哥好帅
Shure: If everyone says Jake is so handsome...
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Alice:有那个大众点评哎
Alice: There's that Dianping app.
Alice:不对那叫啥来着团购
Alice: No wait, what's it called again, group buying?
Jake: 100个币889是吧
Jake: 100 coins for 889, right?
Tasha:  这个会不会便宜一些
Tasha: Wouldn't this be cheaper?
Shure:  应该差不多耶
Shure: Should be about the same.
Jake: 就这样吧
Jake: Let's go with that.
Jake: 够还行
Jake: That's enough, it's fine.
Jake: 哦不然还得剪是吧
Jake: Oh, otherwise we have to edit it, right?
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Jake: 又是一个离谱的数据
Jake: Another ridiculous number.
Katrina:  这多少
Katrina: How much is it?
Jake: 对吧
Jake: Right?
Katrina:  84 他这89
Katrina: 84, and his is 89.
Katrina:  应该差不多吧
Katrina: Should be about the same, right?
Katrina:  老板觉得5块钱不是钱
Katrina: The boss thinks 5 bucks is nothing.
Jake: 他动了
Jake: It moved.
Shure:  啊你需要点一下对哦对
Shure: Ah, you need to click it, right, oh right.
Lucia: 好神奇
Lucia: That's amazing.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Shure:  来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on.
Alice:一人抓两把得了
Alice: Each person grabs two handfuls.
Lucia: 是多少个啊
Lucia: How many are there?
Katrina:  你会抓娃娃吗
Katrina: Do you know how to grab dolls?
Shure:  开玩笑高玩好吗
Shure: Are you kidding? I'm a pro.
Katrina:  我没抓到过
Katrina: I've never caught one.
Jake: 我我们我们也抓去
Jake: We, we should try too.
Lucia: 123456789
Alice:来两个吧
Alice: Grab two.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们也抓吧
Jake: Hahaha, we should try too.
Jake: 你你我看你我我拿拿俩吧
Jake: You, you, I see you, I'll grab two.
Alice:我们一起抓吧
Alice: Let's grab together.
Alice:啊我不怎么玩
Alice: Ah, I don't play much.
Jake: 哎对可以啊可以啊你可以
Jake: Oh, right, you can do it, you can.
Lucia: 我再拿一个吧
Lucia: I'll grab another one.
Jake: 没事没事没事没事找我领就好
Jake: It's fine, it's fine, just come to me to get it.
Alice:你想抓什么
Alice: What do you want to catch?
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 很出师不利的
Lucia: This is not going well.
Tasha:  我带你去玩一个
Tasha: I'll take you to play a game.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 是不是不只抓娃娃呀
Jake: Is it just claw machines here?
Jake: 别的
Jake: Or something else?
Lucia: 对别的也可以
Lucia: Yeah, other stuff too.
Lucia: 就是带币
Lucia: Just need tokens.
Lucia: 一般来说是通用的
Lucia: They usually work for everything.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Lucia: 您是多久没回国了
Lucia: How long has it been since you came back to the country?
Jake: 哈哈哈真真没来过这些地方
Jake: Hahaha, honestly, I've never been to places like this.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 你给我一种至少10年没回国的感觉
Lucia: You give me the feeling you haven't been back in at least 10 years.
Alice:来上去吧
Alice: Come on, let's go up.
Lucia: 有人要玩跳舞机吗
Lucia: Anyone up for some dance machine?
Lucia: 哎 95
Lucia: 这可以让修硕来玩
Lucia: Shure can play this.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这好可爱
Lucia: This is so cute.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:乾坤未定
Alice: The future is uncertain.
Shure:  你我皆是牛马
Shure: We're all just working hard.
Alice:牛马
Alice: Working hard.
Jake: 这是浪费了我一个币子是吧
Jake: Did I just waste a token?
Jake: 哈哈哈那那边有那个架子鼓
Jake: Haha, there's a drum set over there.
Alice:三个吧
Alice: There are three, right?
Shure:  啊有吗
Shure: Oh, really?
Lucia: 那边有架子鼓
Lucia: There's a drum set over there.
Lucia: 你要不要玩一下
Lucia: Do you want to play it?
Jake: 围观你打一圈呗
Jake: Let's watch you play a round.
Shure:  来一波吧
Shure: Let's do it.
Lucia: 让我观摩一下他玩
Lucia: Let me watch him play.
Jake: 这行吗这设备够灵玩吗
Jake: Will this work? Is the equipment good enough?
Jake: 可以是吧
Jake: Is it good?
Jake: 等会我把大家都叫过来
Jake: Wait, I'll call everyone over.
Jake: 你先等会
Alice:给你拍个背面照可以吗
Alice: Can I take a picture of your back?
Lucia: 星星越少难度越小
Lucia: The fewer the stars, the easier it is.
Lucia: 哎哈喽
Lucia: Hey, hello!
Lucia: 又绕过来了啊啊
Lucia: Came around again, huh?
Jake: 什么OK OK
Jake: What? OK, OK.
Lucia: 没事又绕过来了我说
Lucia: It's fine, I said I came around again.
其他人：单位打车到这得多少钱
Others: How much would it cost to take a taxi here?